Tyra Banks is going back to school I'm
really really proud it's kind of surreal
the 45 year old took to Instagram on
Thursday to share this pic of herself in
her dorm room at Harvard Business School
that's right
Tyra is living in the dorms y'all this
is crazy and this is fun in the caption
the supermodel explained why she's
hitting the books revealing that it's
all about prepping for the launch of her
upcoming attraction model and think
Harry Potter meets Willy Wonka quote I
came to the business school many years
ago with the model and dream in mind and
now launch is so close I have returned
to school to refresh the knowledge I
gained and to make sure I am more than
equipped to bring you an attraction like
you've never experienced before a place
that allows you to be the fantasy
version of yourself
vo model for date many body camp Tyra
continued thanking her professors adding
that she hopes to make them proud model
and is my legacy it will be something
that will outlive me ET caught up with
Tyra in May and July model and is all
ages all races all skin all body types
and she couldn't help a gush over model
and a 21,000 square foots ticketed
attraction that lets people be the dream
versions of themselves through various
interactive entertainment curated retail
and user-generated content a model and
will redefining what a model is it is
massive and I'm ready to change some
more lives
you